[MUSIC]
Hi, and welcome to Georgia Tech.
My name is David Joyner,
and I'm an instructor and
course developer in the OMSCS program.
>> My name is Eboni Bell, and
I'm a current student in the program.
We're here in the Klaus Advanced
Computing Building, the headquarters for
the College of Computing and
its masters program.
As you start your journey as a Georgia
Tech masters student in the online
program, we want to give you all
the information you'll need to succeed.
>> Over the next several lessons, we'll
go over some of the basic facts that you
should know about the program itself.
We'll also go over many of
the tools that will comprise
the majority of the time you
spend in the OMSCS program.
We'll also give you some tips for
success that we've gathered over the
past several semesters from students and
instructors alike.